says we can live and we are we're live
okay excellent
so uh hello and welcome to round table
with the stream team this is where we
sit and we talk to content creators and
ask them you know what they did to get
them becoming you know where they are
today
so tonight I would like to welcome to
the round table respond TV is a good
friend of mine who I've known for what
do we figure out almost three years
almost three years three years yeah
so how things go good I've been very
busy but going pretty good overall good
happy to hear it so the other the other
members of the table they are actually
out on personal stuff they hopefully
will be back next week so I wanted to
you know I wanted to make sure that I
got some person here that we has big
opinions great ideas great thoughts and
someone that I knew who would be around
for you know for a really good
conversation for everybody so respond
tell me uh you know tell me where you
started and what's going on you know why
did you become a content creator Wow
that's a loaded question let's just
start from the beginning okay
all right so I started like most people
watching streams and watching YouTube
content and all that jazz and what comes
with that I was a viewer of twitch ever
since Justin TV so I've been watching it
for a long long time and one day I just
struck up a conversation with a streamer
called John Sandman bank before he kind
of blew up because he's kind of big now
especially in the rocket League parts
but um and just talk to him about it
talked about streaming and like how he
enjoys it and you know what he uses it
for and I'm a very outgoing person so I
wanted a place where I could free and be
myself you know you know be able to talk
however which way you wished exactly
exactly and you
I just I had a conversation with him and
decided let's fire up a stream and see
where it takes me
and that was almost that was actually
over four years ago now that I had my
first stream so so we ran so where would
you end up starting with then I my first
stream ever was life as strange when I
played life is strange yep and I played
that all the way through and then from
there it was I jumped into like sports
games really early so I jumped right
into like NHL and then I played NHL for
I don't even know three months and then
just kind of bounced around here and
there after that well the life is
strange was my first one well from from
what I can recall I started seeing you
when it was just kind of towards the
tail end of your minecraft days oh yeah
so you you end up going into like
minecraft and then after that you kind
of jumped to a lot of those tilted games
right yo so minecraft I did that for
almost six months I did nothing but
minecraft stream and that's where I
probably got besides NHL that's probably
where I got the biggest bulk of my like
followers and viewers was from minecraft
and then yeah after that I did because
minecraft fun I really love minecraft I
do but after a while it's just like I
can't even look at this game anymore
no I can't build anything else like I'm
kind of creative but minecraft create
creative is a completely different beast
yeah you have to have a very creative
mind to make some things in Minecraft
well yeah after minecraft yeah I jumped
around it in telltale games I just did
variety stuff this is kind of like
whatever I felt like playing that day I
just played it and that's what I did for
probably a good year to before I found
em will be the show yeah so you prefer
playing sports games sort of you can't
are you kind of like teetering all out
of sports games from from our I know
from our previous conversations that I
know this
leading you a little bit but you're kind
of so you're kind of venturing away from
them now or are you kind of like you
know they're still there but you know
there's nothing really holding you there
so sports games are great just because
I'm very competitive so having runners
oh my gosh yeah it was a blast yeah
and I didn't wait I was pissed you and
blunder and squall I was just like yeah
yeah we've super competitive
but sports games are always good for
that you know just to kind of build up
my competitive nature because I was
competitive I play sports I follow
sports I'm a huge huge sports guy so
I'll always play sports games and I do
enjoy them it just gets to a point where
the game gets like taken out of my hands
where it's it's not based on skill it's
based on AI or computer or algorithms or
whatever yeah just choosing the outcome
and that's when I kind of venture away
from it because it just makes me the
competitive nature and me just makes it
just makes me angry so yeah I mean with
M will be the show because that's what I
did for months even last year and then
this year it got to the point where it's
just like and I don't even like
streaming just because I'm not enjoying
the game I'm playing yeah so yeah I'm
kind of venturing back into playing the
game I want to play that way I enjoy
actually being here for a stream and
playing it yeah so so right now you've
been playing for durable orderly
industry oh yeah everybody we've had for
the past three weeks everyone's come on
here and they'll be like Borderlands
it's great Gears v and borderline says
well that's what we've had everyone's
saying and that game is the it's just
got so much you know feeling to it that
it's just like I can see why everyone
wants to play it and why everyone's
enjoying it it's spectacular I mean
looter shooters are I think some of the
most addicting games ever made so
besides like wow of course but I guess
in a way wow
I mean it's chasing loot I mean that's
that's that's a big thing with Wow well
yeah Porter is great the mechanics are
great everything is great about the game
so far I've now see for me personally I
feel like wow you know it gives those
people that wanting for loot that it
kind of pushes people to want to have
loot and if my brain serves me right
Borderlands came after a while oh yeah
so they probably saw how people kind of
got thirsty for and they were like
there's no first person shooter looter
game like this let's see if we can make
some algorithm to produce a lot of
weapons and feed that feeling and yeah
that's where that's where that feel came
from so I fully understand that one I
have I have the all the past three
borderlands games Jessup Orleans
Portland's one quarter lines - but I I
just never have the time to play them
and once it so the third one was coming
out and I was like if I pick this up I'm
done I'm like I I have so many other
games and backlogs I'm like I can't do
it so I'm waiting until it comes out on
sale which is smart yeah just mark yeah
cuz portal III it's like you you you say
you don't the time you have the time to
play it it's just once you start though
it's over for you cuz it's like wow I
have to play this you know six hours a
day for the next three months or I'm not
gonna feel complete yeah yeah so I
definitely understand that so when when
you got partnered cuz you are a partner
twister Emer that was when almost a year
ago almost year ago yeah a year ago and
yeah you were playing sports games
during that timeframe yeah all sports do
you think do you feel that the the
sports genre of games that the the
people are attracted to that more than
non sports games so like do people only
watch sports games well I think about it
like Monday Night Football a lot of
people watch Monday Night Football a lot
of people like I know the guys from the
podcast on Sundays they cut their
streams early so that they can end up
watching football on Sundays because
yeah that's the feeling do you feel like
that's kind of like the similar fashion
then yes
yeah yeah I mean I don't I don't stream
during lines games at all on Sunday like
my normal start times around - I don't
do that cuz the lines are on yeah and I
normally I usually end up watching games
even after that so yeah oh yeah yeah
absolutely
when you look at Sunday like if you if
you have people in your channel who are
who follow sports a lot like when you
look at Sundays like just by the numbers
like Sunday's are gonna be lower just
because everybody's out you know
barbecuing and watching the game and
hanging out with family and friends yeah
yeah it's so I kind of I kind of see it
as and and like a lot of people when we
decided hey we're gonna do this podcast
on Sunday so like are you sure you want
to do that it's Monday Night Football
and I'm like I understand that but it's
only you know what twelve weeks out of
the year so so during during your the
time that you started like that growth
what what do you think kind of helped it
what kind of things like helped you do
that was it like the type of equipment
you had it was just you know the the
networking that you had was that the the
people that you met or what did you
think I don't think it was ever the
equipment that I had I mean we we had
this I've had this conversation with
people all the time
like when you're streaming and first
starting out or even not even just
starting out your personality can pull
in a lot of people like you don't really
need like webcams and lights and like
green screen and all that stuff you just
stream from a PlayStation or stream from
an Xbox I'd be completely fine I think
the big thing that really helped me
growth wise was finding a community that
I was passionate about and that was
really just the sports community in
general because I'm really passionate
about sports I enjoy the games I enjoy
the communities too they sometimes they
get bad reps just for being like you
know toxic or or something that nature
but um I think the biggest thing with
growth for me was finding a community
that I embraced and then
braced me and I was passionate about it
and I was decent at the games so I think
that's definitely what helped well are
you are you talking about impact because
they or the group like you're you talk
about the the people you met after that
the people I met with in the sports
community okay like the streamers in
there like networking with them you know
streamers I like breezy and jurors and
mills and you know guys in the sporting
community like networking with them and
also the viewers that came with it they
enjoyed the content that I brought and
they enjoyed me as a content creator so
everybody just kind of stuck around for
that tight-knit sports community yeah
cuz I I know that when I was but I was
watching your channel watching and
seeing you do your thing and I saw this
I started seeing that influx of people
coming in and it was very refreshing
because it's like me personally I'm not
a sports person you know I I was there
because I I knew you and I've known you
forever and I was like I'm gonna support
you so I'm gonna be there so that's why
I was I'm always lurking and you know my
friends channels throughout you know the
days the nights and everything and I I
was very amazed by the amount of sports
knowledge you have because yeah yeah cuz
some of the stats and some of the
people's names I was just at they're
going who are these people
I'm like I have no I have no idea and it
was I think that that was kind of
refreshing to your audience
yeah people make fun of me because I'll
pronounce the name wrong or something
like that
yeah your knowledge is great when all of
my chat just makes fun of me for my you
know lack of knowledge in certain areas
it's hilarious well it's your you
probably way better pronouncing people's
names in May we're crazy
someone just not you look at it and
you're like I have no idea
so you're just throwing a ball you're
like what I don't understand this same
with switch names some people come in
you're like you look at it you're like
I'm gonna call you George house it's
every time I go into a new person shot
right and I sit there and I watch them
and I just sit there for a while I'm
like do we like him - I like him and
then I hit that follow button I thought
I watched their faces going now smelly
it was snow it's not exactly that every
time when someone's like yeah yeah it's
snow though right now that I'm like yeah
that's fine that's enough you're good
it's like that face of confusion that is
funny I don't even know if I've ever
asked you that how do you actually
pronounce your name well it goes well I
say sonali do so there's there's two is
to do it so okay a lot of people call me
Snell DOE and my sister-in-law and my
brother they've always called me snaily
do and it doesn't matter to me it's as
long as it's close it's fine but okay
I'm gonna screw in your name when I'm on
the podcast and the guys tried to
pronounce my name for the first time
they were like we're not gonna call you
that
I'm like just just call me Pete that's
fine that's the only person that I knew
from the podcast was the main host
Cognito and he's sitting there he's like
the only reason why I know your names
because I worked with you the other guys
were confused so when you when you
originally started streaming you were
straight out of respawn uh yeah I
actually had another my yeah I had one
before then okay wait blown Las Vegas
I'm sorry what
it's called Pueblo Las Vegas it's a long
story that's about a like a friend like
ten years ago
but is it a funny story not really
oh not at all actually but um I did one
stream off of that and it was rocket
League and that was like
way way back and yeah I just stopped and
like I'm like okay streaming is kind of
fun and that's when I yeah I created
straight out to respond like that's the
main the main shape yeah so that was the
channel you've had for the longest
amount of time and then yeah the four
years though and you've only recently
changed it to respawn TV about eighteen
eighteen months ago I think and around
there yeah so what was the what was the
name change for any particular reason or
is it just because you're like oh I kind
of consolidated make a little more
unique or couple of things so whenever I
went into a channel and like just said
hey what's up they everybody would look
at it and be like straight because it's
long it was a mouthful yeah it was like
straight out of reach straight straight
out of respawn what's up like everybody
everybody did that unless they knew me
and I'd always just say just call me
respawn like I would always say that
just call me respawn where we spawn and
finally just for kind of like my my
brand branding purposes I guess you
could say and just making it so
everybody calls me respawn anyways mm-hm
so I'll just shorten it up respawn TV
and that was pretty much the it was just
it was a mouthful and I had to shorten
it up yeah because it seems excuse me it
seems like a lot of people will oh I
should say streamers when you go into
their channels did they see those long
names and they just kind of like like we
were saying before they kind just look
at it like side either like what yeah
they just said I do it do yeah I do when
somebody comes in with a really long
name it takes me a second and I usually
just end up shortening it anyways so
yeah it was just it was a pain what do
you what do you how do you how do you
feel like you connect with your with
your viewers do you kind of sit there
and you kind of talk to them about like
certain things or is it just because you
kind of connect on like the same gaming
level or how do you how do you feel like
you connect to your viewers when you're
talking to him I think all all the above
I mean I connect to people on a personal
level because I mean I've been through
a lot of stuff in my life so I can kind
of relate to a lot of things and I've
had a lot of friends who have gone
through really bad things in their life
so I can I can kind of relate to people
so I can definitely do it on a personal
level I mean also like a like a
knowledge base to just because most of
the people who come in are usually very
knowledgeable on whatever I'm playing
mm-hmm so you can kind of connect that
way as well I would say mainly though I
connect with my audience on more of a
personal level than anything yeah plus
I'm also a very open book I'll tell you
whatever is on my mind if I don't like
you I'll tell you if I like you I'll
tell you I mean it's I was gonna ask an
awkward question but I held back boxers
or briefs
let's go boxers or briefs long-legged
briefs game-changer anybody who has done
it especially if you're bigger
especially if you're a bigger person
with long-legged brief suit with a
changer I'm talented with with the thigh
rub so my question is um boxer briefs
long long legged bracket breeze okay are
you uh are you gonna be going to any
conventions like this year coming to
next year or anything like that you have
any plans you plan on going twitchcon
next year you plan on going like you
know III any of those things
taxis whatever probably 93 I'd like to
get it out to PAX East next year 100%
I'm going to twitchcon I went there I
went there three years ago absolutely
loved it met a bunch of people went to a
bunch of different like events and and
discussions it was great I just I've
been had a lot going on I've also been
quite poor
so twitch counts kind of been out of the
out of the discussion but next year 100%
I'm going and I'd also like to go to PAX
East
yeah uh as well two things one
you have two people in chat there
they're actually confused with your
decision for four boxer briefs and
long-legged boxer briefs I just want I
just want to make sure you realize that
so I think it's a game changer I'm
telling you you're a bigger dude and you
you know how the the briefs are the
boxers they kind of ride up a little bit
I'm telling you long-legged boxer briefs
are the way to go change your life so
there you go final final words from
Febreze blowing so the the podcast
ourselves we always go up to to PAX East
every year and we we love it until as
many people as we can that if you are
going to speak to indie developers or
use their to just speak to really almost
anyone in the gaming world that that is
one of the best conventions to go to and
it's fantastic as for networking I i
I've been wanting to go to twitchcon for
probably past two years so I I mean it's
I agree with you the money different the
money change is a changer trying to go
there because you know you're gonna go
there you're gonna drop like five grand
easy if you go there yeah when I the
last time I went it ended up cost me
about $2,300 now granted you know there
was a lot of additional costs in there
for some things but yeah it was about
twenty three hundred bucks last time I
went to twitchcon it's definitely
expensive
well did you go do you get a lot of
merch there too cuz I feel like a lot of
people buy oh yeah no I got a bunch of
merch and I went to really really nice
restaurants a couple of times and the
hotel it was like like up two blocks
from the convention center's Murray
expensive and like yeah airfares
straight flights like it was kind of you
know is a vacation there too or no no no
time I feel like there's no time I feel
like when everybody goes right they
usually go to Disney or they go to the
Oyster Cult don't they of like a mass
effect type park over there
maybe my room maybe it's a Bioware park
maybe I think I was too busy meeting
everybody because there's a lot of
people that you want to meet and hang
out with and everything I had there was
there was no time and then not enough
time in the day I slept like maybe an
hour and a half a night and there was
still not yeah I when when we were when
we were doing our PAX East thing what we
end up doing is we we interview so many
people and we literally get there when
it opens and we start all of our
meetings and just back-to-back-to-back
one right after another and then
Sunday's are usually are our clean-up
day so when we go there I last year I
was just like I'm done I'm going home I
bounced it like 10 o'clock I took an
earlier train home I was just like I
can't I was like I can't do this anymore
I'm like it's too much I'm too tired so
I mean I could fully understand when
you're when you're it's it almost turns
into like not a vacation or a fun time
it feels more of a what I'm looking for
like almost like a work work type the
work trip okay that's how I kind of felt
like it was but what is what is would
you say is your number one favorite game
air taco said one of these decades they
need to have a twitchcon on the East
Coast I agree I fully agree with you it
only the only reason why they I don't
think they'll do that is because most of
the developers and most of the twitchcon
twitch streamers are all in California
it's true that's that's where they all
are
so for them what they end up doing for
handful of the bigger partners and
streamers is they actually pay for
everything room board all that stuff
actually and the people that are on a
lot of the panels if they're invited to
go into a panel they pay for the room
and board into a panel and all that
stuff the whole entire time they're
there so that's that's why I don't think
they'll ever have it on these oh no the
weight the weight which has been growing
they added twitch Europe as well I mean
you I mean in the future you never know
you could see a twitch West and then
touch which east and then the twitch
Europe and just have three
twitch conventions a year yeah I mean
you could definitely see that especially
the way that twitch is growing yes I
don't think it will ever solely be on
the East Coast
yeah it'll always be West Coast so we we
ended up having dead butch Chico on this
past weekend for the on to the iron
Lords podcast and he is the CEO of play
craft and he ends up producing
conventions called play NYC play Seattle
play though you said he's working on
another one in DC and I think he has
another one in California and he ended
up just starting this theater being in
New York for the past four years and he
said it took them four years to finally
go into the green on their convention
and the growth on the dimensions
themselves are amazing with all the
developers and all those people on there
and hopefully over time that twitch will
end up seeing that it's not only a West
Coast game and it will be on the East
Coast I I pray because I want to go to
them but it's just it's the time and the
money is just I can't do it but yeah
yeah so um what is your favorite game
ever plane of all time of all time do
you have one Wow your shirt right now
Mass Effect
no I like the Mass Effect series but
it's not my favorite I would have to say
probably oblivion Elder Scrolls other
scrolls ruin lesbian did you ever play
did you ever play the MMO yes I did I
put a lot of time in the ESL really a
ton of time before I started streaming
yeah oh wow and yeah you haven't played
it since has changed over no I haven't
played in years years years years I
haven't played ESO
but I know that it's still doing alright
and there's still quite a few people
playing it has a good player base still
yeah I I ended up picking it up for
about a month the month or two ago just
to play on my off time I walked in I was
like I want to kill a dragon
I literally ran out of the temple there
was a dragon there and I killed it and I
was like sweet and done kill the dragon
yes so it was really really good I
enjoyed it a lot but it's just not
elderscrolls yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
of living in Skyrim I think both those
are probably pretty close I mean I put
in oblivion in Skyrim I've probably
because I streamed sky room a bunch - I
probably together have done probably
close to 3,000 hours and I'm really I
would say yeah cuz I've played through
him beat him multiple times and then
when you get into the mods and
everything it's yeah it's great is there
is there any game you're kind of like
looking forward to the next year I mean
last of us - man last of was - that
trees and I was just salivating I was
just like this looks so good and let
last of us is probably up there as one
of my favorite game at least story wise
that game was absolutely stellar so uh
when I was watching the trailer and some
of the stuff I saw let's see I don't own
a Playstation I I know it's terrible I
really want to play Last of Us and less
than us two and two when it comes out
and a bunch of other games on
PlayStation don't even get me started
but the I saw her and I was like she
looks like Lara Croft killing people and
I was like wait yeah I was like that's
awesome Ellie's all grown up yes she's
kicking ass yes yes err taco yes did we
ever play EverQuest did you ever play
requests negative I did wait look at
time ago and you want to know what hmm
time of my life I will never get back
and and it still makes me cry it's here
tonight I can't tell you how were the
Warcraft
eirick
I still played World of Warcraft's
because I'm stupid but I literally can
tell you there's been nights I haven't
slept waiting for a boss to spawn going
to sleep waking up in my chair and then
seeing the dead body not something I
recommend oh no one ever quest okay
noted noted and stored railways nope
what was the number one game that you
ended up playing that ended up giving
you the most viewers you would say and
will be the show the show give me give
me approximate number when you want max
or average uh give me Matthew me the max
cuz you know twitch numbers are accurate
yeah I think most I had and will be the
show was for sixteen yeah I've had I
mean I've had like I've had big people
raid me or host me before like I know
I've had where it's like you know eight
hundred for three seconds before it's
gone but uh yeah I think it will be the
show the most was a little over four and
then yeah I just I did really good with
them Emily the show and then after that
probably minecraft the good old
Minecraft yeah going back to my other
question from before I went before we
you know chat was asking questions do
you what is the first game you can
remember playing do you have a really
good memory or experience uh I remember
I don't remember what it's called but it
was I'm a little so my grandma and an
Atari and it was one that you had like
this was your controller and you slid a
little yeah it is know what it was in
television yeah okay yeah yeah buttons
and everything and yeah and it was a it
was a tank game where you drove around
as a tank and you just shot other tanks
was probably called tanks
and probably I don't know yeah but
that's that's the first game i remember
playing that's that is awesome like a
lot of people when they think of their
first experience they can remember the
console but they can never really
remember the game is not the norm i go
against the grain man always always so
when you when you started streaming
right so let me take a step back so
people kind of know more about you so
you specifically only stream or do you
do youtube do you kind of what would G
what type of stuff do you end up
creating III stream yes I just fired the
YouTube back up and I've been putting
out a little content here and there
there mm-hmm that's I mean that's pretty
much it I do everything like I'm I like
on my own I do all of my graphics so I
use Photoshop I do all my graphics I do
all my panels all of my emotes all of my
sub sounds I have like kazoo is a big
thing for me and I do all my sub sounds
like kazoos and I do all that stuff all
of it by mine so where did the kazoo
thing come from I've always wanted to be
honest to be honest I actually don't
even remember it's been so long and
there's a there's a song called it's the
it's a kazoo remake oh my gosh I gotta
find who it was made by but it was it's
a kazoo remix and I it was a it was a
YouTube mic diva
it's called kazoo kid trap remix so I
listened to that thing cuz I subscribed
to Mike diva I listened to it when it
first came out and I was like wow
there's that could be a really good sub
sound so I just made it and then that's
where kazoo was born and I've kind of
embraced it
I don't know it's all stem
from a YouTube video is that as uh is
that kind of your your now your icon
your kind of like your that's your thing
yeah because news my thing dude I can
play it pretty good actually
[Laughter]
I'm not bad at the kazoo and if you
stopped my stream listen like all of my
like most of my sounds for alerts are me
playing the kazoo and adding in
different things for audacity it was
actually funny I uploaded a YouTube
video and I got a copyright claim
because one of my song I call it I call
it uh I call it the pink Panther's ooh
because it's the Pink Panther but it's
me playing the kazoo it was so good they
copyright claimed my Pink Panther
rendition on the kazoo like yeah I think
writing I take pride in that I take
pride that was something I didn't know
and I have a bunch well like I have like
green I have red orange purple and I
have a bunch more I have a gold one and
in there yeah so once you once you
started like getting all this stuff
together and like what what type of
where did you kind of start you were
like oh I'm gonna take a PC I'm gonna
take this microphone camera work how did
you kind of start you know your that
process of being a content creator oh
okay I did I did something that I
suggest nobody does I started right off
the gate I bought everything I had a PC
so that was good but I bought two
monitors I bought a webcam I bought
lighting I bought a mic I bought a
little like mix am I bought these
headphones I've had these since I
started I went out and just
everything because at the time had a
pretty good job so I was like and I
never I never jumped like a foot in I
like go headfirst I dive I dive in
almost everything I do so yeah I started
right out the gate go just getting
everything and saying I'm gonna try to
be the best that I can be at this you
you totally Ash Ketchum did yeah yeah
yeah I did yeah
well that's like look we're discussing
before cuz because of your straight
competitive nature you were just like
I'm going all for it I always do that's
that's I dive headfirst into everything
yeah how did you how did you like family
kind of you know react to you saying hey
I'm gonna I want to be a full-time
streamer do it was it were they kind of
like supportive or they kind of like
questioning it do they have no idea what
streaming was because that's what most
people are they were both like what's
what's the streaming what's the strata
so my sister hundred percent in yeah
biggest fan from day one she was there
all the time her and also her partner
Angie they were there all the time
always supporting always great mom dad I
mean they're in their 60s so I mean they
know they'd lately know twitch and my
mom will come in and watch every once in
awhile but they were just like what are
you doing oh people are watching you
yeah I think it's kind of weird you're
letting him into your house kind of
thing
so they've always been there they're
better now but they've always been a
little like yeah but no my sister has
always been my biggest fan in the corner
yeah did you give your parents excuse me
did you give your parents like a cool
like twitch name so when they come in
there they're like mom a respawn or
something no no my mom picked their own
name and yeah yeah
but um yeah my dad he doesn't have a
twitch he doesn't have a touch god he
could barely he can barely work an email
he just got his first smartphone so my
dad still does not have a smartphone we
support phone we
phone beep no and I got him a Google
Apple TV Oh dad here's an Apple TV it's
gonna be way easier for you to use you
know see Netflix and I put everything on
and he goes I don't know how to do this
it's going like this with it I'm like
that you gotta go slower than that it's
like I think you should go I'm like oh
my god
sorry I want to ask though you
introduced your father to the Apple TV
I'm sure Netflix too as he like really
embraced Netflix like watch it all the
time now yes yeah yeah so yeah I I first
started him off with a oh my god I can't
believe it
um the chromecast I gave him a
chromecast I had an extra phone sitting
around so I was like I'm gonna put
enough looks on there here you go and he
gave it to my dad my dad he is a man
that works with his hands he's very
hard-working
so he has like all those calluses on his
fingers the problem is is that when he
hits the smartphone it doesn't recognize
it cuz of the calluses so we had to get
him a weird so my wife she ended up
getting one of those pens so he ends up
using a pen and kind of he's kind of got
used to it kind of started enjoying it
started using it and he actually uses it
way more than I thought he was so now he
now that we gave him the Apple TV now he
just has to learn how to control his
swipe so it's not like across the screen
that's the only thing he's got to
control now but he he's getting so much
better with it it's so much worth so
much worth it
it was so good for him yeah my dad he
retired so like we introduced him to
Netflix and Hulu and oh my gosh he's
been going nuts he's been what he's like
me just watching all the documentaries
that netflix has to offer
he's been going crazy I don't think so I
don't think he's seen it oh I Oh 100%
you see the new trailer came out today
well not a new trailer was kind of like
a little splash for it first range of
things season four no I didn't I'll send
you the link later okay yeah yeah it
really does
so much it's kind of just like it's kind
of losers fine for me it's kind of like
a little bit it's exciting yeah little
yeah so it's good it's good mmm do you
when you're when you're streaming a lot
of times you get like people that are
just like really toxic that come into
your channels or you are they mostly
just kind of like embracing to your
channel oh no you're always if you
stream you're always gonna get people
hoard toxic and trollee I mean that's
just that's just part of the game I mean
yeah it happens all the time how do you
end up kind of you know reacting to that
do you kind of just take them and ban
them depends on how I'm feeling really
um one of my mods Lola I don't know if
you remember Lowell wolf but um one of
my he started as a really really really
bad troll and I just slowly just turned
him into just watching and then he kept
coming back and watching and eventually
he's just he was there every day for
like a year and a half so yeah it just
it depends on how I'm feeling that day
sometimes I'll troll them back if I'm
feeling that sometimes I ignore them and
just let the mods you know timeout or
ban them yeah and sometimes I do it
myself and play a little hello darkness
my old friend the holes like some yeah
sometimes sometimes I do that you know
it just depends I don't know depends on
I'm feeling that day depends upon you
know what's going on how's it has it
going with it so yeah have I had a bad
day am I feeling kind of chipper and
happy you know I don't know it just
depends so what what do you end up doing
when you get some like free time so when
you're not well you're not streaming to
you kind of like you go out or is it
just mostly just work you're at work you
just working sorry I just work in stream
man and if I mean sometimes I'll of
course I'll hang out with like family
and friends I quit drinking so I don't
really going out just isn't the same for
me anymore but yeah if I'm not if I'm
not streaming I'm either you know
driving because I do Oberon lifts or I
am in Photoshop or working on different
sounds and audacity or
I mean helping people build pcs that's
something I do I make people emotes you
know every now and then on the side I
mean it's just I'm always I'm always
going do you do you feel like the way
that you're kind of like rolling right
now is kind of is good for your your
happiness level like it's a good it's a
good for you feeling feeling good
feeling like everything's a lot better
than the way it was past couple of years
from where I'm coming from yeah oh yeah
I'd rather be doing this and working all
the time than doing what I was doing
before cuz I'll slowly put me in the
grave yeah well we wouldn't I know when
you're past two jobs yeah maybe it was
two jobs and I remember knowing you
right before those transitions you were
ready to just shank somebody and it was
yeah I was an alcoholic I mean really
liked that job kind of drove me to that
and it was it was weird cuz like every
Friday and Saturday if you came to my
stream you knew that I was gonna get I
was gonna be hammered mm-hmm guaranteed
like there was no ifs ands or buts mhm
and like yeah that job was yeah job was
bad one of those things that you always
had and you haven't done them lately
it's used to do Fridays and or Saturdays
you would do like community nights
almost now we would end up doing was it
killing for and stuff yeah and then
running the runners runners speed
runners yeah jack box party packs we
used to do those all the time yeah now
for eff eff you eff effed up Fridays yes
do you yes do you feel like that kind of
helps like bond your community kind of a
couple held everybody together yeah I
mean sure you definitely the community
games were always fun I enjoyed them it
just they weren't the same once I quit
drinking I mean that's really what it
came when it came down to yeah and
another thing that was really weird is
some people they came to the stream
expecting to see me hammered so I guess
that was probably one of the detriments
but yeah doing those community nights
those are great me you wolf blunder
squall I mean all everybody coming
together to play the Jack Emperor
another one playing the jack box party
pack games and their running games yeah
that was that definitely helped bond the
community who do you think as of right
now is the person that has been around
the longest for you in your chat that
has been a bigger like a big supporter
for you holy cow didn't expect that hard
dude it's just there's so many like I I
always I look back at it you know
sometimes if I'm like down about numbers
or something that's like there's been
sad three three and a half I mean it it
is there's there's so many I can't just
pick what I'm buying YouTube YouTube
what you doing to me it's a bunch at sea
we've been looking good having some
internet problems over there
I don't know Bram's mm-hmm Thank You
Internet fantastic
hello darkness my old it's like those
one days you don't want that to happen
and it happens oh I know well well we we
can keep good we can keep going it's
okay I uh I'm putting on a local record
no not Comcast actually have Isaac
optimum online believe it or not but uh
optimum online yeah yeah
it's uh it's a service provider it's an
Internet service provider out on the
Long Island in the city I will out from
New York City yeah it should be back now
but it has a fantastic Internet backbone
it's actually one of the top five on in
the u.s. cable I'm sorry I per or cable
it's cable Believe It or Not which is
surprising because they have a almost
like a fake fiber so they they tell
people that they have a fiber network
but they really don't so well you know
if they if they have fiber for a hundred
feet they can probably say that they
have
yeah but that's the thing being a person
that works in the IT industry
you kind of know when when things are
good when things are wrong and one of
the things is with little islands is
that if it's fiber it's gonna be the
same up and it's gonna be the same down
so it's gonna be a hundred down hundred
up that's just how it is playing simple
okay so this I have 350 down 75 up so
cable that's cable yeah yeah hundred
percent yeah so yeah it's a total total
liar t22 people tell you it's cable but
you know it is what it is
I missed fiber with our last house had
fiber had gig up gig down yeah so we
know Comcast it's a thousand down and 35
up 40 up that's weird yeah little off
yeah I will say this though I have the
google onhub is my the type of router I
have and I can't tell you anything but
good things about it that's good to know
so it's really it's really nice device
I'm sorry I'm sorry we got we've got a
little distracted
yeah via the Internet thank you very
much Internet it's better now fantastic
good Matt be it's kind of working better
now so what type of things the which I'd
like challenges what type of things that
you kind of encounter when you when you
started streaming and when you wanted to
produce that growth for your channel did
you have those stumbling blocks did you
have any of those things that you you
ended up getting to mine were mainly
just life like past jobs having to
travel for four months so having to just
completely put the stream on hold right
like no stream for four months sorry
guys being in the hospital and being out
of streaming for two months I think a
lot of my a lot of my challenges been
that I'm a firm believer of like you
if you if you put in the if you put in
the work right if people really enjoy
your content if you're always trying to
improve your networking you're meeting
new people you know you're getting into
just something that you're passionate
about I think it always works out the
end I really do if you're just if you're
never trying to improve yourself or I
don't know I mean some people definitely
get into rats and I've been there but I
don't know do you feel you feel like it
like it you can always build a good
community do you feel like the
consistency helped absolutely oh yeah
consistency is a huge thing and people
think like you can take a day or two off
like that's that's not a problem I mean
some people might not come back I mean
it's definitely a dog-eat-dog world in
the content creation but like you can
take a day off here or a day off there
the people who are loyal and want to
watch your content they'll always come
back to watch your content they really
will so consistency though is big yes I
think a schedule definitely helps as
well I'm a firm believer in a schedule
instead of just well streaming at one
today and then streaming it ten today
streaming at midnight now I think a
schedule is very also key and just a
consistent schedule do you do you feel
that because you're you're you must like
flips your schedule a little bit because
before you did a lot of nice dreaming
now you doing more day streaming you
feel that kind of helps you helps um
initially no I would say initially a
lien ated a lot of people who watched my
stream a lot at night now they can't
anymore so I think at first cell but in
the long run I think it does help
especially like for the afternoon like
morning and afternoon a lot of people
are work so a lot of people will watch
streams at work there's definitely a lot
less people streaming so I
think that doing morning and afternoon
it's always better than being in the
main night crowd at six o'clock at night
when everybody's off for streaming right
yeah that's that's something that I've
kind of noticed also that those
nighttime streamers are you know they've
they have that a little harder because
because of the you know you you're
walking home and you know people are
gonna have like you know a 40-person
option instead of like a 20% option
during the day exactly so I fully fully
get you at that and I fully understand
it and for like discoverability as well
like when they get home they usually
want to watch you know cuz a lot of the
bigger streamers they'll stream at that
time just because that's when they'll
get usually you know the most viewers so
when people get home they want to watch
them instead of watching somebody new so
I think discoverability also kind of
takes a kick in the butt night as well
did now you what would you consider
yourself like a variety streamer or just
play what you like streamer I can play
what I like streamer yeah I think that
was that that's a very good way I save
variety just because I've been playing a
bunch I would say I'm a sports streamer
until I get sick of sports and then I
just play whatever I feel like well I
remember you played a crap-ton a
fortnight I really enjoyed fortnight for
a long time yeah I went a lot what made
you what made you walk away from it ah
they changed the game too much like I
really enjoyed the game where it was
they just I think they they did too much
too fast for me they changed like every
season it's like a brand new game which
is great for some people but I kind of
like I don't know I like the old hits
especially with those games I think
that's why I'm I always sometimes I'll
hop back into pub G cuz now they've
changed things they've optimized they've
added new guns and stuff but and it's
core pub G's still pub G I will say this
and probably a lot of people hate me for
it I I was hoping you were coming to
Division two and hang out
but you know I know that you uh you you
kind of wanted to step away and I
understand and a lot of people are
complaining about it right now
but I understand I own it you own it for
the PC no oh no I game share with Xbox a
friend of mine and he bought it so I own
it no I haven't touched it haven't even
loaded up got it for nothing and I still
haven't touched it
see like I I I will tell you this
sometimes those games are that you never
touch her are gonna be the best ones
like I've never laid like I've never
played Skyrim before and I know I know
it's so good god of war oh my god I I
want to play it and spider-man which I
remember mom you play and it was amazing
so good so good spider-man and God of
War both are really good well which
which is do you think is like your game
of the year so far right now right now I
mean man I've I have I've only gotten
like thirty forty hours into it but
Borderlands 3 is a game that it has it's
been a long time since I've had a game
that's like sucked me in to like I have
dreams about it kind of thing I think
order lines 3 is shaping up especially
once they you know give us the free
content there's a Halloween event coming
I mean got the DLC I think that's easily
gonna be Game of the Year Jesus do you
feel like they're gonna end up taking
Borderlands and kind of like molding it
involving it kind of like other ways
that the mmo's do giving you seasonal
content giving you kind of those new
fields every kind of month a couple of
months to kind of keep you in the game I
think they'd be stupid not to I mean
there's still people who play
Borderlands 2
I mean Borderlands 2 is huge it had a
really big people just getting in and
just grinding for gear and and doing
things with viewers and stuff like that
I think they would be silly not to just
be
even if they released and I'm sure that
they gearbox never will but even if they
released like a store for skins even I
feel like they can make an absolute
killing if they give you content upon
content like content upon content like
every two months the game could go
forever yeah I I've I've said this
multiple times and I know that's a it's
used to be we when we were in PAX East
we saw we were at the Borderlands reveal
oh nice it was amazing rady Pitchford he
was you know up on the stage and he was
he was probably one of those CEOs that
everyone should have in their place and
they should have been because he really
he really wanted to show the work of his
people he really want he's really
passionate about his game and they he
communicates directly to believe it or
not those cosplayers because there was
probably about a dozen cosplayers there
with new outfits from Borderlands 3 that
hasn't even been revealed yet
he ended up contacting them directly and
knowing hey listen this is what we're
gonna do blah blah blah blah blah here's
what these people look like do you want
produced cosplay for him and he was
talking to them directly in DMS via
Twitter and some of the costumes and
stuff that these guys came up with and
it'll like took him two weeks I was like
there's no way in hell I'll be able to
produce that in a year I was like in
these kids in two weeks just this one
this one woman created a tiny Tina mask
that lit up and I was like what that
would literally take me years and some
of those cosplayers are crazy they are
they make some wild stuff I was I was
like that's very impressive it was very
very good
I was I was happy with the how they
ended up doing their thing and
performing I feel like they've been
working I feel like they've been working
on this game for so long there's no way
that they haven't planned out
like they're kind of showing it like
this free Halloween event it's free
content gives you a free zone NuLu like
there's no way they've been working on
this long and they're just gonna do DLCs
I think they're gonna be sprinkling in a
lot of that free like probably gonna be
like a Christmas one in a New Year's and
I'm sure they're gonna be sprinkling
those in right the next year let's I
agree I agree I think it's gonna I think
it's gonna be good I think it's gonna
hold a lot of people's attention until
after the holidays because November we
got a lot of new high end games coming
we end up having you know Star Wars
fallen Jedi yep I am pumped are you I am
on the fence I'm I'm a Star Wars man I I
will drop everything for Star Wars and I
told and I told I told the people that
put Warcraft with I told the clan that I
played Division two with and I said
November 15th don't expect to see me for
a week I'm gonna start it and I'm going
to finish it nice that's all you're good
that's all you're gonna do you have to
give me a review oh how you like on on
Lords of gaming net and it'll be on
there and it'll be on me iron let's
podcast YouTube channel
I always I always put reviews of games
that I really really enjoy and things
have changed good stuff so what is your
alright this is gonna be the final
question for you so you can think okay
think think long think long hard and
good for this one alright okay if you
okay if you can live in one fantasy or
video game world what would it be for
instance would you would live in the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter would
you live in the world of Mass Effect's
would you live in you know though the
world of of the Star Wars universe what
like what would you do
where would you would you live in no
man's sky
fortnight why would you were tonight
it's a terrible I don't know Oh think
about it they what do you what do you
think oh my gosh that is that is a tough
tough tough question any place or any
fantasy world where would I live man
it's gonna sound a little strange and a
lot of people might not even know what
it is oh it can't be as bad as what we
had on our first our first episode okay
what you have on your first time Silent
Hill why would you live in Silent Hill
someone wants to live inside out and
that was somebody from our panel from
the old school said he would live in
Silent Hill so trust me I've heard
senior things
is he a psychopath in the land of
silence like why he goes I know it's
coming after me I'm like I'll take it
okay I kind of like it
so okay my favorite book series of all
time is a book series called red wall
have you ever heard of red wall no
please please enlighten me okay so man
how do I even begin to describe this um
think like children tea I guess it's
it's for anybody but um you know
watership down have you heard of
watership down no the rabbits it's on
Netflix now they made a movie it's about
the it's about the rabbits the hares the
bunnies that like a real vicious and
they're always fighting you know
oh my gosh sorry top um okay dreams
[Music]
appreciate it no okay so red wall is
think Lord of the Rings but with animals
interesting you got you got foxes you
got hairs you got squirrels raccoons
it's this whole entire world of like
Lord of the Rings Skyrim there's magic
arrows sword fighting all an armor
everything think of that but with
animals so I love animals they're cute
they're adorable I absolutely love them
so I think living in that kind of world
I would definitely be a fox I think
living in that kind of a world my
question is what does the Fox say I had
to say it yeah the red wall series it's
it's really long I mean if that sounds
like it's and it's a big book series I
think it's over 2000 K the guy's been
writing it well he's he's passed now but
Brian Jacques he's been writing it for
his entire life
so it was like I don't even know 30
years yeah that's really good dude do
you still have time to read or not
really any more I try to I mean a lot of
a lot of my readings skewed more towards
like knowledge things like no
biographies and stuff like that but yeah
yeah I do yeah what I read it's about
the stupid stuff that I just want to
shut off my brain like I just want
something ridiculous well Maze Runner
perfect for you man exactly exactly
oh did you yeah oh my gosh I actually
really like this Maze Runner was too
cold Hunger Games
I'm huge in the Percy Jackson series
okay so Rick Riordan I have all he has
one two three he's always technically on
his third Percy Jackson series I've read
them all he's actually working on a
fourth one I'm telling you those are the
type of books I go forward just because
they're easy rates I don't have to thing
right yeah that's it on the I would pick
it up in the Kindle and everything there
I have never a room where I live for
books so why don't you why don't you
tell everybody where they can find you
you know tell them all your other
information all your digits oh man
so you can find me and twitch and
respawn TV you can find me on youtube
every spawned TV Instagram which I
haven't posted anything on there yet but
I'm trying to get to it every spawn TV
pretty much everything is respawn TV
except for Twitter that's respawn twitch
on Twitter they wouldn't let you have it
there mmm I think it was already taken
really I tried to get it but it was
already taken yeah because I know that
there's a reason why I didn't yeah it's
already taken jerk yeah I know you have
to contest that I agree so uh I would
say thank you very much for for coming
in tonight for hanging out I I greatly
appreciate I hope you had a lot of fun
time so great just just a couple of just
a couple little things before before we
head out l-boogie just so you guys have
an update she's finally hit the West the
East Coast she's doing good she's doing
great
started a new job today check her out on
Twitter l-boogie oh 208 she is on there
if you want to talk to her she should be
coming back in the next week or two ish
old-school-style
he is it should be his final week at
overnight so he'll be back
MJ is a boss is once again doing his
schoolwork stuff and you know I we had a
conversation with him today and I was
like buddy you got it you got to get
this stuff done it's College you get
you're on it you're awesome
and I can't wait to have you back but
you know get this couple of things done
and he plans on doing that so I like to
say thank you everybody else for hanging
out ere taco coach oh thank you very
much uh-huh Huck I'm sorry thank you
very much for hanging out so if you are
looking for any more information about
us Ireland's podcast is on Sunday nights
at Sunday days I should say at 11 a.m.
for because football season is here we
do it earlier
away from football season we'll be back
at 1 a.m. on Sunday and we'll do that
Lords of game Annette is the website
we've got all your gaming news there's a
lot of information there reviews lots of
gaming information lots of tech
information go check that place out the
place is amazing it's awesome
we are the round table with the stream
team as you heard all of our all of our
friends right now have you know personal
obligations that they could not make it
this week I've been holding down the
fort with my with my sword and shield
like nobody's business
so thank you very much for hanging in
there I appreciate it
if you guys have any more questions for
any of our streamers that are coming
onto the show please email us at round
table stream team at gmail.com next week
hopefully we're gonna have MJ back as
long as school is kind of a little
better forum because he should be
cutting back a little bit on time
because of vacations and such so thank
you very much the episode will be up on
iTunes and Spotify Google's podcasts
there's so many that we have a coming up
on they'll be coming up on Thursday
mornings so you guys can see it
I am Stahl though also known as Pete I
am on Twitch Monday to Friday usually
7:00 to 10:00
unless I am here because I enjoy being
here with everybody
I love having someone like respawn here
you know hanging out and talking to him
asking all those hard questions box is a
breeze
so you know thank you very much and
follow us on a table stream we so you
can check out your notifications see
who's coming on next week see what's new
what's happening all that stuff please
check out the iron Lords podcasts
Twitter those guys are amazing though
they guys content like nobody's business
I greatly appreciate now everybody
remember dream big and keep gaming thank
you very much everybody
have a fantastic night a fantastic week
see you soon bye